hey friend oh god you're still mourning
silent Hills aren't you no I'm sad
because you're leaving who's leaving you
are and Sam leaving early they serve
great news we're leaving early today no
no you're going is that right going
where you're leaving the company the
company of heroes no no no we're leaving
her company when we leave early Oh jack
oh I'm sorry because you two have quit
your jobs you're leaving me here alone
so this is like all the times that I've
had to say goodbye to video game
characters that I've really loved and
just let me really sad so luckily for
such an occasion I prepared a list them
hmm shouldn't you be working Oh Elton
John reckons sorry seems to be the
hardest word when in reality it's
probably goodbye sure in a grim post
pandemic world you're gonna be saying a
lot of them but the most heart-wrenching
of them all came at the beginning of the
last of us amidst the chaos of the
cordyceps outbreak Joel's daughter Sarah
gets caught literally in the crossfire
leading to a rather distressing death
that plagues Joel for the rest of the
game similarly in the walking dead it's
wise not to get attached especially to
kids the scene where protagonist Lee
says goodbye to his ward Clementine is
heartbreaking but not as bad as when
Kenny had to watch his wife kill herself
and then he loses his son duck to
infection more heartbreakingly depending
on player choice as the option to have
Kenny kill his own son after finally
reuniting the reformed John Marston with
his family and red dead redemption we
thought we get to live the happy ranch
life but no rockstar games had other
plans and after ensuring his family
safety John gets trapped in the pond and
takes one final stand against
overwhelming odds cue sad music on
didn't improve in final fantasy 7 we're
beautiful bad guys sephiroth's decided
to summon an entire meteor into the
planet the only thing longer than his
silver hair was his blade which he
drives clean through erith as she prays
for the meteor busting white materia
holy we all watched it bounced down the
steps and into the abyss shortly
followed by air of herself life wasn't
easy for Dominic Santiago after
both his children on emergence day his
wife fell into a deep depression
eventually disappearing and when she
resurfaced Dom had to euthanize her she
was traumatized through torture Don
proved a loyal and reliable member of
Delta Squad eventually giving up his
life for them in an emotional finale and
now he can never listen to mad world
ever again and finally depending on how
recklessly you played no one's really
safe in mass effect in 3 we knew we were
gonna lose some beloved faces but the
one that sticks out for most people is
Morgan's death everyone's favorite
Gilbert and Sullivan singing silurian
sacrifices himself to save the krogan
and why him someone else might have
gotten it wrong whoa that was sad and
what's that got to do with us it's a
metaphor for how I feel about you guys
leaving but those guys died am i dying
no you're leaving therefore you're dead
to me I'm dead hungry lunch oh yeah oh
you guys are even sad about this about
what Oh Tory would point have to decode
this enigma when we leave games for this
week damn right I can't believe
shouldn't even remember we're going oh
well bye everybody goodbye look sad damn
it it's got to do with us guys die am i
dying where's my homie force is strong
on the feeble-minded shoulders okay
isn't it that's the HR HR handbook wait
I pity that poor child just warn you I'm
gonna go for shoulder all right is that
high five was as good as our work we've
done together oh that wasn't hungry
speech spontaneous hug yeah look at you
know it's a friendly murder don't touch
your eyes
right Oh God great we release their yeah
they're yeah well so long hey Lou